[Musique]
je mangerais bien dehors quelqu'un
connait un bon italien dans le 18e tu
peux manger en italie
il va d'abord falloir l'attraper mb
google est ton ami
oui j'ai cherché sur google et j'ai rien
trouvé c'est pour ça que je demande
désolé mais moi j'ai cherché avec mandat
que j'ai trouvé des trucs achète un mac
vous pourrez valider chez pramac comme
ça tu auras plus d'argent pour s'acheter
à manger achète un pc à force de plantes
et tu pourras faire un potager
ah ouais super à la blague ah ouais
super tamer super ta gueule connard
calmez vous les gars et sinon mon
italien
il court toujours là qui roule on met
une espace avant un signe de ponctuation
double désolé je suis un gamin nazis une
grand-mère nazis
tu fais jeunes pourtant attention pour
le continent c'est goodwin sans aile
paul roll bonjour yoyo ces moments qui a
envoyé un mail sur le facebook de mon
téléphone parce que la souris te plaît
sur internet je fais comment bisous
moment je sais pas vraiment cherchant
google
[Musique]
tu pleurniche pour un resto alors il ya
des enfants qui meurent de faim en
afrique pas raciste mais africain ok et
sinon personne pour moi pour manger
italien
le mieux c'est d'aller au métro robe à
moi je connais un super héros dans le
19e par contre libanais il était
aujourd'hui tu vas faire à manger toi
même ce serait moins cher surtout qu'à
part une éponge cru oui quand je choisis
par paris à dire certains à prix et qui
se plaint la wii moi j'habite à rouans
manche trois ans maintenant
[Musique]
bon ça fait un an que ça me travaille et
je crois que je vais quitter facebook
peut-être pour un moment peut-être pour
toujours chez pas j'avais cru naïvement
que venir ici ça allait combler le
manque affectif qui me bouffe un peu
tous les jours mais je me rends compte
que les interactions que j'ai ici ça
n'arrange rien le plus dur c'est pas la
solitude c'est le bruit tout autour du
cou je prends les choses en main parce
que c'est roman comme m'habite
voilà donc la situe clic-clac tu peux
abonnés le bo est en bataille sketch h
et l'artiste est caché je te déteste